on va poursuivre avec Said à tout dico
et les professeurs au Département des
sciences comptables de l'esgukm experte
en gouvernance bonsoir madame dico donc
vous avez lu les 700 pages faut le
mentionner vous avez 89 précisément
beaucoup de lecture donc la nuit
dernière qu'est-ce qui vous frappe le
plus là dans ce rapport
mais il y a plusieurs éléments parce que
en matière de gouvernance pour une
entreprise de ce de cette envergure là
qui se présentait comme une entreprise
de rang mondial il y a un certain nombre
de prérequis à avoir un minimum à avoir
en matière de gouvernance et dans ce
minimum là il y a le ce qu'on appelle le
système de reparti donc le système
comptable de l'entreprise qui était en
fait quasiment fait à la main
manuellement pour une entreprise qui a
15 entités normalement on devrait
présenter ce qu'on appelle les états
financiers consolider et on apprend dans
ce rapport que c'est manuellement que
l'entreprise essayer de présenter les
états financiers contre des équipes
totalement
en fait moi j'étais à base d'ordi à lire
ce rapport-là donc on se rend compte que
il y avait un laxisme incroyable dans le
système gouvernance en matière de
reporting mais aussi très important pour
un secteur d'activité comme comme
celui-là un manque de de gestion de
risques ce qui est quand même
incompréhensible parce que c'est quand
même l'argent des gens c'est monsieur et
madame tout le monde qui a mis son
argent là-dedans ce qui est perturbant
madame du coup c'est que on voyait là
une série de drapeaux rouges exactement
depuis un bon moment quand on commence à
se fait qu'il y a pas d'autorité
réglementaire qui est signalé ça en fait
comme dans toute nouveauté parce que on
s'entend que c'était une industrie quand
même c'est un secteur d'activité qui
était
en plein effervescence qui est nouveau
qui suscité beaucoup d'engouement avant
la chute que tout le monde connaît
maintenant et donc c'est comme si à
chaque fois qu'il y a une nouveauté on
ne se questionne pas nécessairement sur
les gardes de fou on y va à fond parce
que bon il y a un engouement qui est là
alors on y va à fond on ne contrôle pas
on se questionne pas sur la
réglementation donc ceci explique cela
et souvent malheureusement c'est
lorsqu'il y a un scandale lorsqu'il y a
un problème qui éclate que on se rend
compte que finalement on aurait dû
et ce qui est ce qui est décevant c'est
qu'au passage il y a des investisseurs
qui perdent beaucoup
ce qui est particulièrement perturbant
parmi tous les éléments le bon
évidemment la comptabilité sur quickbook
quickbook on s'en étonne mais le fait
que on l'apprend dans le rapport des
employés à l'interne qui évoquaient
ouvertement l'idée d'un stratagème à la
poésie le mot a été prononcé
est-ce que ils sont autant même à blâmer
que le chef la direction c'est quand
même c'est vraiment incroyable il y a
même un des employés qui a évoqué que
son titre aurait dû être un consultant
en Ponzi tellement c'est c'est c'est
c'était évident en fait que il y avait
des pratiques qui ressemblaient beaucoup
à ça est-ce qu'ils ont le même niveau de
responsabilité c'est sûr que le niveau
de responsabilité je pense va dépendre
aussi du poste occupé par les employés à
mon humble avis le chef de la direction
était quand même le premier responsable
de tout ça mais il y a quand même une
responsabilité de la part des empl et
surtout en fonction de leur poste donc
on peut s'interroger sur est-ce que ils
auraient dû lancer une alerte est-ce
qu'ils auraient dû bon dans quelles
conditions tout ça a été fait comment
ils étaient aussi impliqués on se rend
compte aussi que le chef de la direction
avait quand même appui empocher jusqu'à
70 millions de dollars dans toute cette
affaire là donc jusqu'à quel point les
autres employés étaient impliqués dans
dans
ces transactions là donc c'est très
opaque on ne sait pas du tout mais il y
a quand même je pense que
individuellement dans une société il y a
une responsabilité individuelle que
chacun de nous doit peser et prendre et
la Caisse de dépôt de placement
là-dedans madame Zico bon est-ce qu'on
leur a menti est-ce qu'on a tentait de
leur présenter un bilan enjolivé ou
est-ce que la caisse n'a pas fait
complètement son travail qu'est-ce que
vous pensez qui est arrivé
une structure comme la Caisse de dépôt
et placement et certainement une
structure dotée de nombreuses expertises
en matière d'analyse financière en
matière d'analyse d'investissement et
donc on peut pas penser que il y a pas
eu d'expertise par contre on peut penser
peut-être que
on n'a pas nécessairement fait toutes
les vérifications parce que je ne peux
pas croire que si on avait fait un
minimum de vérification qu'on ne puisse
pas s'apercevoir que il y avait un
problème avec tous les drapeaux rouge
qu'on voit dans ce rapport-ci donc
probablement que l'engouement
au niveau de ce secteur d'activité là
peut-être faire en sorte que la caisse
et aller parce qu'il y avait quand même
un engouement important à ce moment-là
je ne pense pas que les experts de la
caisse aux vêtements s'ils avaient fait
ces vérifications là qu'ils auraient pas
vu des problèmes donc
on se pose questionner effectivement sur
c'est quoi le niveau de vérification qui
a été fait plusieurs questions qui sont
toujours en suspens d'ailleurs parce que
le dossier est toujours devant les
tribunaux question auxquelles les
québécoisses vont espérer avoir des
réponses un jour madame dico très
intéressante merci beaucoup d'être venu
ça m'a fait plaisir pour voir nos
émissions en entier rendez-vous sur la
chaîne ici RDI